if you want a job jumping into people's
content on LinkedIn and actually leaving
a thoughtful answer leads to incredible
job opportunities if you want to build
if you're not tripping or the sooner you
can start building leverage for yourself
through content or through the brand
you're creating the better but it's a
mindset conversation the one thing I can
promise is not going to do anything for
anybody here is playing it out in your
head and doing nothing non-action is the
devastating thing so what he's referring
to is I put out something a couple
months ago maybe half a year ago called
the dollar eighty strategy the way to
win is to listen and then contribute my
point was everybody was trying to grow
on Instagram it's such a big thing for
everybody and I said look there's you
know it's kind of like getting into
shape there's a right way to do it and a
wrong way to do it I said the right way
to do it instead of like follow and
unfollow people or what LinkedIn is a
disaster everybody just spams each other
and in the inbox right you guys know so
I created something called the dollar
eighty strategy which is really what I
would do if I didn't have the size of
the audience that I have now and it's
actually what I did do on Twitter in
2007 my point was and by the way anybody
who has a physical location you can like
you can search on Instagram by interests
hashtags right you can search by
neighborhood you know Columbia Maryland
place you go to places right so I'm in
internet search right judge this is
gonna work for all of you if you want to
build so you just go to Columbia
Maryland and right now it's gonna show
you all the top photos and all the
recent photos like you can search by
every photo in Millburn New Jersey so
Wine Library does and I said look at the
photo and then leave a comment that
means something first photos like a dude
who's like looking real [ __ ] diesel
and [ __ ] so like I mean you could you
could like and this I'm not joking I
would literally go in here be like swole
post I did like just a you know for our
liquor store like people like Boeing the
long we're like well lit it'll be like
long do you want a beer after this like
we'll make a joke or you know and and do
that and I call that leaving your two
cents and then I said do that 90 times a
day you're gonna drop a dollar eighty a
day two cents at a time nine top posts
times ten different hashtags every day
and that will massively build up your
audience and that's your dollar eighty
strategy the way you can do that on
LinkedIn the great thing that's happened
on LinkedIn now is it's become a content
platform as you guys know it's not just
a utility anymore to get a job there's a
ton of content in there search things
that matter to your world read the
article then leave the best comment in
the comments section and use all the
attention of that person's audience by
leaving a meaningful thought in the car
guys it's so crazy how very basic my
advice is it's that it's it's not easy
to implement in the same way that like
staying in good shape is not easy it's
easier to not eat well and not workout
it's easier but um that's how I would do
it you know there's two ways to really
attack content produce it or engage with
it but most people when they engage with
it are like me me me you know like I
just you see it all right like people
leave a comment like yeah if you agree
with him sign up for my nobody gives a
[ __ ] about that it's like all the guys
tonight in Vegas that try to get people
to go to their room on the first word
it's not gonna work it is not gonna work
you're not that handsome hey guys thank
you so much for watching my video on
YouTube I wanted to jump in here at the
end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty six bottles of wine
a year or give away thirty six bottles
of wine a year please sign up for Club
empathy this project means the world to
me
that could really use your support
you